take him down yet
no we're at fifth tower but still
waiting on the warrant mind if i join in
on the fun
you know how his lawyers are this one
needs to go by the book come on yuri
i've been waiting eight years for this
you really want to help
head to times square sounds like his
guys are trying to keep my backup from
reaching the scene
you got it almost there find him end
this
not yet we just picked up chatter
they're wiping all their data servers we
need that evidence if we want to put him
away for good okay server room it is
let's see just how good their security
is
oh you guys forgot the latest kernel
patch
says the guy frantically erasing his
search history
true but that's part of my charm isn't
it
when you're free get out fast if you can
walk help the injured got it
[Music]
go go
[Music]
oh my god
writing your memoirs
don't forget the hyphen between spider
and man
get the chopper ready i won't be long
i'm surprised you made it this far
but your foolishness
ends now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so should we kiss now
yeah maybe later
[Music]
i'm sorry i'm late
you started without me the grant
committee's director will be here soon
it's fine parker i invented this
equipment i think i can handle it
it's a disaster
how could the damn nerve failed
i know doc said take the day off but
i have to figure out what went wrong
[Music]
too short to be spidey too skinny
kid
george your face already you freaking
say
vigilante